let me show you this let me show you
this let me show you this just just in
the last 30 days this is what's happened
i saw two articles so if you want to
pull this up uh one of them is what
hillary clinton said one of them is what
rand paul said i don't know if you heard
this i'm sure you did so if you can pull
this up a little bit higher a little bit
higher there you go with the picture
shown perfect bitcoin could become world
reserve currency says senator rand paul
this is october 25th
a little over four weeks ago right this
is what he is saying world reserve
currency says rand paul hillary clinton
just comes out a week ago or two weeks
ago this is a week ago she says
she fears bitcoin will undermine dollar
as world reserve currency which one is
more likely to happen or will both
happen
so i think they're both talking about
btc bitcoin because that's what people
assume i think it is incapable of being
the world reserve currency it doesn't
have the capacity to settle anything
near what would be needed in in
bandwidth terms btc is heavily crippled
it does not work it really really only
works for what people are using it for
today which is an investment asset front
run people get other people to buy it
you've become more rich and that's great
and that's really
everything that's going on there it
cannot do even with the layer 2 stuff
all of that stuff is is a lot of
vaporware and the stuff that works
really only works in
bubbles
and so i i think frankly they're both
wrong but where they're right is that
the bitcoin protocol what satoshi
nakamoto actually
invented is capable of doing that it it
should absolutely be a both and it
should be a frictionless digital cache
it should be a tokenization layer it can
do smart contracts worldwide right now
in fact is doing it uh but it's on bsv
so what bitcoin sv is
and this is why craig wright and all
this stuff is tied together is that
bitcoin sv is bitcoin as it was
implemented by satoshi nakamoto so
there's no swim lanes in the protocol
so whatever you want to try to do if you
want to try to push an entire operating
system in one transaction and then have
tokens interact with that operating
system all up in the stack you can do
that it's not going to stop you so
miners might stop you if you don't pay
in a fee the miner may not mine it and
put it on on chain i think the token's
pretty interesting because you could i
could anyway see a future where
every city has its own currency for sure
it's a token that's you know bitcoin
based or or some sort of blockchain
absolutely there be instead of paying
cash to get an mta card to ride the
subway in new york you'll have new york
will have its own coin it'll have its
own token yes and digital currency like
pat was you know we were talking about
earlier there there was land sold in in
in uh
universe which is nuts to me man because
one of my favorite quotes from the
sopranos was when tony soprano you know
tries to give fatherly advice to aj it's
like buy land god ain't making no more
of it god's making more land now it's
digital land that's crazy no it's true
so i mean you know the go go west young
yongsan westbrook expansion and and this
is 40 acres and a mule and this is and
this is why so
this is why
i i'm such an advocate for the bitcoin
protocol which again in my belief really
only exists in bitcoin sv
it's the only one that can do those
things so right now like and just for
clarification bitcoin sv is different
than btc correct so they both break that
down they're both based on the bitcoin
protocol in a very basic sense so
it's it's kind of like the the judaism
christianity lds
islam and all these things like there's
forks right but they're fundamentally
abrahamic they're fundamentally
abrahamic religions right so this is
this is all these bitcoin variants are
fundamentally satoshi ish
implementations of bitcoin including
things like litecoin or purecoin or dash
all these things are still like 95 the
same thing at the very base level but
the way they're implemented has has a
bunch of different variables and so btc
is bitcoin but implemented with a bunch
of the stack turned off so the op codes
the stuff that would allow smart
contracts a lot of it just turned off
because like ah that stuff's kind of a
security issue we don't want to play
with that also we don't want more than
six megabytes per hour to go across the
whole network or else people in the
third world won't be able to operate
nodes and we want everyone to be able to
have an endpoint on the network isn't
this what ripple wanted to do but they
just
were dumb enough to incorporate in the
united states yeah i mean ripple's the
same thing ripple is is also very
similar to bitcoin in most ways that
matter so almost every blockchain is
basically just a derivation of the same
idea so what bitcoin sv is is okay we're
going to implement bitcoin but we're not
going to have any hard limits on things
so whatever you want to try to do
whatever economic actors want to push on
the economy and see if they can create a
market create an economy with a new idea
you can do it on bsv today like ethereum
you can't do it the nfts on ethereum
aren't even actually on ethereum you own
a string of numbers you don't own the
artwork in fact people are getting
censored off of ethereum right now for
their political cartoons like if you put
a political cartoon that is unsavory in
some way you can just eliminate the art
because the art is sitting on open seas
server or it's sitting on aws or it's
sitting maybe on ipfs but that art
disappears and you only own the hash
bitcoin sv right now there are like 3d
objects as nfts
made in i mean you can grab them you can
play with them but they're on chain
they're in the blockchain that can't be
deleted and that's the only blockchain
that does it everybody else is selling
you a string of digits and they're
hosting your file on their servers and
whenever they feel like you know what
i'm done with this they shut the server
off and you lost the piece of art you
think you own let me let me ask you do
do you own any bitcoin or ethereum
i i own a little bit of a lot of things
but a lot of it is is old school like
i've been in the space for nine years
now so some of it is i probably have
stuff that i don't even know exists at
this point but it's smart not to answer
with joe biden's guy right now no no
what do you mean that you know doesn't
exist does that mean um so i mean just
in testing like if we're going back to
2015. so i actually used to be an
ethereum miner i was mining monero in
2016 and 17 like i've i've gotten myself
into a lot of things to like what is the
most recent coin you invested in were
you bought recent um
bsv i'm heavy in the bsv space got it so
when you so let's talk about the mining
the difference between ethereum mining
and bitcoin you'll see uh uh one of the
arguments will come up to mine one
bitcoin cost you know you hear somebody
the forty eight thousand dollars forty
two thousand dollars etc etc explain to
the average person what it means that it
costs 42 48 000 to mine a bitcoin or
mining ethereum which is what you used
to do yep um so what you're doing when
you're mining is you're actually you're
trying to brute force a number so the
network says find this number and here's
a bunch of math problems to get you
there and then what you do is what's
called a brute force so you get a bunch
of computers to test is it this number
is it that number is it this number is
it that number but they're doing it at
an incredible speed and just absolutely
bonkers speed in fact this is the most
uh progress in computer science and
moore's law and all this stuff has been
toward breaking hashes specifically for
hashing on on blockchain assets so what
you're doing is you're hunting for
one number and in bitcoin that is a shot
256 number and on ethereum right now
it's it's eth hash which is a i'm not
going to get into the the math and
science of it because nobody cares but
um
in ethereum you use gpus so it is like
the graphics cards that that people want
on their gaming computer this is why
gamers hate crypto people because they
can't get the gpus to make their games
cool because they just keep getting
bought up by ethereum miners primarily i
hate the crypto people they do
and so what you're doing there is you
can run a gpu farm which is quieter it's
a lot less energy efficient but it's
it's the best way to mine ethereum today
and and so a lot of people gpu mine and
that's what they do on shot 256 it's
specifically asic mining which is
application specific integrated circuit
meaning it is a computer that is
designed to do absolutely nothing but
look for bitcoin hashes
and so it's very very heavily
specialized whereas ethereum miners when
they're you know if you decide you know
what i don't want to be an ethereum
miner anymore you put those gpus on ebay
and sell them to the gamers again and
the gamers oh there's been a drop we get
to do this so but ultimately what you're
doing as a miner you're looking for a
hash and that's really all you're doing
what's a hash
a hash is um it's a string of numbers
that represents some other thing so i
can make uh let's say i write the number
my birthday and then i run it through an
algorithm it will spit out a hash and
the algorithm can always connect that
hash to my birthday if that's what i
want it to do so it's a proof of the
existence of the first thing
but hashes mean it can be something as
simple as a as a very simple uh like
like my birthday written out or it can
be a whole novel like i can make it moby
dick i can make it the entire library of
congress and i can hash it and the hash
will be the same size regardless of the
input
correct it is digital dna it's a
fingerprint that points to the proof of
existence of another thing
but in a way that is uh standardized and
easily attestable
so that's what they're looking for
they're looking so why does it cost so
much money though
because it's competitive so specifically
it's if i can do it better than you
then then i will because i'll make that
money but if but if gerard figures out a
new way to do it maybe he's got better
uh
whatever but better computer science
background or he can pay somebody to
build a better chip then all of a sudden
he's more rigs more energy he's more
competitive than us then i need to
figure out oh shoot what do i do like do
i go to the third world and try to find
an old diesel plant and make it that my
power is cheaper or whatever so it's
this competitive nature it is free
market economics 100
at play that makes it that i'm going to
compete with you but then you're going
to compete better but yeah
why is the argument about it
the reason why bitcoin will never end up
being the currency is because it costs
so much money and it's it requires so
much energy and power right why do why
does that constantly come up um because
most people are communists and they
don't realize it so people that talk
about costs without talking about roi
are
dim period it's roi
this guys
you say anything bad about communism
this guy's trying to make out with you
on camera it took off you're on your
head i feel unbelievable you want such a
level kirk
this guy's slightly uh poking out right
now
but it's true though so the cost the the
cost conversation is fine but but people
that talk about cost without roi aren't
having a real conversation these are
people that that should go get a minimum
wage job and stay in their lane so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye
[Music]